and in any case I was
kindly asked if I
couldn't step in to save operationally
and that went faster than I would have liked
and
so I said I live then asked
to fly to New York
to the headquarters of rework
Softbank was actually in
the process of buying  Wework because
the only way to save the
mobile market, to save yourself, to
save Softbank, to save the other
investors, the only
way was to take on the
Softbank balanced and
buy it, to control
everything else would really have resulted in
absolute catastrophe  changed
Welcome to the OMR Podcast a global
story that started in East Berlin
as I just heard is
actually it could
n't be the opposite. I'm very excited about someone
who
has seen almost everything in the really international digital world,
on all continents, all the big brands
somehow  but he once
started in East Berlin as I said, he started to
get Advent, thank you very much for allowing me to
be here and I'm looking forward
to the conversation, so let's say East Berlin
is right, you grew up here
and you even somehow
after the walls  came and you were
enlightened 12 13 said, um, voluntarily
continued communism a little bit, right, yes, I'm a Berliner, a Berliner,
born in Berlin, born in East
Berlin, because she always
emphasizes, born in Berlin Marzahn, that
I would sometimes add that to the top
Berlin knows and Berlin
Marzahn knows knows that this is a quarter of
the work of the class and was
and I grew up here in East Berlin
and shortly after the fall of the wall I actually
went to Cuba for a certain
time for private reasons for family
reasons and not necessarily for
political reasons  But of course
it was in a certain way a continuation
of the socialist experience. Yes,
I also studied there partly.
I studied both in Berlin and
in Cuba. I studied computer science,
but as I said I also completed
part of my studies at the University of Havana, so to speak
You can
learn computer science there just as well as in Berlin, so
at least back in the 80s and
well into the 90s, so
to speak, the Cuban
education system was a very, very good one
and
attracted a lot of people from both home and abroad
went to Cuba to study from
Latin America itself from the USA from
Europe from other emerging and
developing countries because the Cuban
education system was very professional and
a lot was invested and Cuba
had a very good education in information technology even back in the 90s, even if
it was of course  later the Internet wasn't
opened up and made free for everyone,
at least the
technological basics of the whole thing were
something you
could study and learn in Cuba and to this day
I think the Cuban University
of Technology is a not-so-
bad university by
Latin American standards
and your parents were
very active in the GDR period, British, no, exactly, I
come from my parents, who are also from
Germany, from East Berlin.
Together with my grandparents, they were also
very politically active, so they come from a
family that was actually involved in
entrepreneurship and
innovation or or  Technology
has nothing to do with
someone from my family, right up to the
Politburo, insofar as
the parents and grandparents were
active in various, let's say, political sectors in the GDR.
Politburo in the youth
organization in the party university
and so to speak, they
dedicated a large part of their life to
the illusion of building a different
social system, which
of course failed
and that ran through the entire
family, there was none of the parents,
uncles, aunts and grandparents who were
not involved in any political
But there were still responsibilities in the GDR
when you
came back to Berlin every now and then as a young guy from the Cuba phase. You
said that at some point you met
one of the capitalists par excellence of
our generation in his
early phase back then, Oliver  and um you
started to build it up when
I met Olli Samba
at the beginning of the
Jamba um just acquaintances or just through
acquaintances and
then came into contact with some of the initial
teams of the business
and was of course from Cuba
comments Coming from a, let's say,
socialist family, it was
an incredible energy
that was confronted by
Oli and and the rest of the then
founding team of Jamba, she has a
vision, there was a lot of
technological stuff that was happening in the
world that
caught people  To have cell phones in particular,
that was something very current.
People had a cell phone in their hands for the first time.
Back then, they had these relatively
large Nokia and Samsung and Motorola
cell phones, well before the iPhones
and that was a vision there was
energy
There was
a dynamic and an
enthusiasm that was of course attractive
and for someone who comes from, let me say, a
not so simple political
family history, it was a
beautiful and positive and it was
a magnetism that naturally
attracted me and that's why  that I
was a computer scientist, so I
studied computer science
and, so to speak, had
already programmed a lot of software myself during my studies,
developed this software together with a
fellow student and then
sold it, um, we
built content management systems, we
built precursors of voice recognition systems back then, the Germans
Telekom sold and others,
so we had a bit of small
entrepreneurial success and then
someone with this entrepreneurial
energy came along and said we're changing the world,
even if it was like ringtones, we're
changing the world, we're building something really
big here, we need a story that
comes from Berlin and I believe the
connection from the first
technological basics that I had
acquired,
the will to make a difference, the will
to do something, the desire to
create one's own identity and
help write a Berlin story from what
later became Rocket Internet and  other
stories were created were such a thing
in English you would say yes no
brainer made
I managed Jumper with
accompanied by the from the beginning
until after the sale to use scope and
very and they have similar to
other technology
startups,
so to speak  developed relatively quickly
but it started, so to speak, in
2002/2003 and, if
I'm not completely mistaken, I think it was sold here in 2005
then I would have sold his news head.
I stayed until 2007,
so I was still accompanying Jamba,
so to speak, even after the sale to them
to the Americans from newscop but I
saw everything during this time
and was involved in everything and especially
the entire international expansion
with support, managed teams,
set up the entire sales department
and then you
went to London. After that I went to London and then
we  We joined forces again as parts of the
old Jumper team, so to speak,
and some others also
took the opportunity to join an
existing startup that had already
been founded, Moneybookers,
and to scale this start up globally
as one of the leading
online companies.  Payment platforms have
been very successful and it has been very
successful. It started
in London back then because the government in
Great Britain was the first bar to
issue a so-called license,
well ahead of BaFin and many
other European countries because
Great Britain was the first country to do
electronic money transfer  regulated
has issued an official license
and we were the first company
with Moneybookers to get this immani license
and were able to set up the
equivalent of a PayPal for Europe and
the rest of the world, which is what it
has become today, so it still sells
a lot  A successful and very
profitable company today means
a conglomerate, a group of
different payment companies that
have been merged, so to speak,
and Manni Burkas, which was later
renamed Skrill, is part of
this group together with paysafecard
and Nutella and various others,
but at some point you are  out again
and took the next step.
Rocket Internet had the idea back then
and had already taken the first steps
towards developing a
large food delivery platform that
focused on emerging markets. At
that time, food delivery models already existed
in countries like Great Britain
Germany in the USA under the names
just eat Rapper and
pizza.de already existed. I think the
Lieferheld was in the beginning
and so
together with Rocket Internets
we took care of setting up
food Panda
So he was the founder and
she also of food Panda and we
initially built the business model in
Southeast Asia
and scaled it in several
countries
such as Singapore Hong Kong Taipei in
Taiwan jackart his Indonesia um Kuala
Lumpur in Malaysia ground and I was
everywhere with on the  ground
so it really started in Southeast Asia,
I think seven, eight or nine
countries
and then
expanded towards the west from there, so we went to the Middle East
as far as the employees were concerned, we were
relatively quick, we had several
thousand employees but they
All the places are also very
different, very different from what
we have done and of course
we go through many iterations as
in previous years and with
other businesses and of
course we tried out a lot of things.
Certain countries or cities
worked better than others at the time
the strategy of
expanding as quickly as possible into as many countries and cities as possible,
then assessing where the business model
works and making an adjustment on that basis.
Southeast Asia was and is
still going very well to this day, it is now
part of delivery Hero, you
somehow worked in the East  very good but of
course we also closed a lot of locations
India was a difficult
market Russia was a difficult market
for many other reasons
no street names correctly so everything was very
very difficult or of course
a lot still had to be developed ourselves because let's
say Google Maps
still worked back then  not the way it
works today, um technological
logistics solutions for the last mile
were not yet available as
they are today via
third parties, which means we
actually had to think up a lot ourselves
at the time the market was still very
underdeveloped and so there were
many, many  interesting surprises,
yes, that
especially in this mode, that
you expand as quickly as possible, you
have to bring thousands of tens of thousands of restaurants onto the platform as quickly as possible, how much
capital did you have in the company at that time for
the company Grace so take so there are
already several hundred million at that time  We
went to the company for funding, we had
meanwhile been active in over 40 countries
with several thousand
people,
we had then later moved the headquarters
back to Berlin.
Originally the headquarters had
been in Singapore but the business
was originally only designed or intended for Southeast Asia  was and
we are later the rest of the world
we are, as I said, Middle East
Eastern Europe Russia Africa
we were in seven countries in Africa
or always with Panda
at the beginning the idea was to do everything with
the same brand. We
realized relatively quickly that  Panda
doesn't reach everywhere, the panda is a
very
Asian animal with an Asian influence
and we then had to build up other brands in various
other regions of the world,
yes we were in the
Middle East and the hellofreuds in
Africa, um also in Latin America,
we also had a lot of them back then
We made acquisitions, I think we
took over over 30 food delivery companies in the end,
the whole thing in the respective countries and
so at the end of the day
I think half of the growth and and
and the success was organic and the
other half
was achieved through acquisitions and
That was a bit of a company that never never
made the sales figures public, but we're talking about
100 million, but
there were hundreds of millions of
sales, exactly yes, but the whole thing
worked out or I
rolled it in, you would say, into the one from
Germany  Coming delivery Hero then
right so it was like that it had
reached an intensity in 2014/2015 that you
probably saw again in I don't know in
2020 or 21.
Strangely enough, every seven to
eight years both
the economic peaks repeat themselves  in this startup
industry as well as the
market corrections and it had so in 2015
I always joked with ourselves and
within the team that it
's not Star Wars, it's food wars, yes there
was, so this food delivery
business model was incredibly popular
received an incredible amount of funding
and that's why at some point in
2014/2015 it was like a
state of war, it was about which company
from the big ones was around the world. There was
a grables in the USA. There was a
just eat in in Great Britain.
Of course there already was  delivery Hero here from
here from Germany we existed as a
separate company and fewer others and it
was actually about who manages to
be the biggest the fastest in a market who manages
to raise the most capital because it is
a winner Texel markets and  um
over the last ten years we've been
doing food delivery models but
of course we've learned a lot
and also recognized that we have to
have as much influence as possible on how the
things are prepared
where the items come from
and if possible these days we say
vertical integration yes that one
If possible, handle every step of this
process chain
myself, in the best case scenario, because
if I handle it myself, only then will
I have 100% control. It was already
somehow in Germany, it always
worked really well and was super
profitable, but they never
delivered and then ended up with
this  The business was sold and then the
whole issue of delivery came along with it and the
issue of execution came into play because
pizza.de was profitable, so to speak, but
the customer loyalty on the
platform wasn't that great
because it partly affected the effectiveness of the
delivery and the quality of the
delivery  But it
was very bad, of course there was no
alternative back then, always in the market or
with one of the first players in the market, there
wasn't much competition because it
only had shares in the end, I mean that
was the case in between.
I got to know Niklasberg privately at the time and
we met  well understood Niklas
had similar challenges with delivery Hero,
had scaled the
business in many countries around the world, so to speak,
complementary to what
we did with foot-panda, we
had relatively little overlap.
Basically, Niklas took a lot of
care of some parts of Europe
Latin America is complementary to where
we were with little activity in the
Middle East or Asia, so
when we met privately we had already
thought about what would happen
if we joined forces and
both had the company headquarters in Berlin
so there were a lot of synergies we
had  were very complementary
in terms of the countries we
were technologically very
complementary in terms of technology and we
just said that if you
combine them together
you generate a significantly better
financial profile and make yourself as a
whole company much more attractive for
attractive for everyone exactly it was for everyone
so we have  futbander and and
delivery merged here as
part of a skull
and then we decided together
to put the combined company on the stock exchange
and then actually
seven months six seven months after
after the mörger we
went public but of course the then right
big payday, so to speak, that was
very successful for everyone involved, yes,
so you can
imagine that because they
slowly arrived over the various deals,
we were fortunately um always very successful over the various deals
and delivery Hero was,
so to speak, the
most successful exit to date
and then you're out of it and then
on and now the
journey starts to get really strange so
to the craziest um say
investors or or founders and
entrepreneurs like that  whatever you
want to say came so what Samba and
then went on and
entered this world I read exactly
before wework there was the Softbank world so
we took delivery on the stock exchange in 2017
um I'm still together with
delivery Hero together  Niklas
Östberg and the rest of the management
team and I
actually stayed with delivery Hero until 2019 and am still
a
successful company and I am
still a shareholder of delivery Hero
and a shareholder despite the development
of evil because of it  I am convinced
that this business model
is and will be sustainable and that it generates as much
customer loyalty as
few other business models, but
as I said, I was still out in 2019 and then
I came across it again by
chance and through references
Softbank management team introduced
at that time there was the global CEO of Softbank
Marcelo Clara, but he was a well-known name,
one of the most famous investors in the
world, which was only clear, who had, so to speak, very
great entrepreneurial success
and who had sold his company Bright Star
at some point to Softbank and
the number, so to speak  Two of Softbank
is the biggest investor in the
world and one of the biggest legendary
people
from Japan. Behind him is a
Mr. Sun who is known in investor circles all over the world
and who is also extremely kind of
right, so I became friends through
references
and mutual acquaintances
Coin investors I had already
successfully built three companies up to now, Jamba was one
Moneybookers was one food partner
delivery Hero almost technically speaking,
four companies that I
helped you build successfully
and also led to the exit and
then became Softbank and  Marcelo Clare
introduced me
to Tokyo to Japan because
it was a
it came through another investor I
think that came the intro came through Sequoia back then
I had a very good
relationship with Sequoia
before and I  I've
also had a lot of involvement in other companies as an angel investor over the course of the last
or the various exits that we've
made.
I've
also been involved in a few
investment funds, I've also
been involved in Sequoia as an investor myself and I've just given this intro
Softbank
realized that they were interested in
talking to me and were
looking for a way to get to me, so to speak, and
Marcelo called me directly and
personally and said Software had
huge plans and they needed
someone exactly like me and, um, they invited
me  politely to come to Tokyo
they would organize the flight for me
hotel anything and
a few days later I was in Tokyo
and had a meeting
with the Softbank management
of the entire region
and they presented me the plan the
so-called Software Unicorn  To
build a farm, that is, Softbank was at that time,
I think, at the absolute peak of
its vision of 100
billion other management,
so the Softbank vision was just
built, which was then the
largest investment to date for the
technology team, 100 billion in
money  Telco area earned and also
with Alibaba I think
they earned a relatively large amount of money
through the Telco area through the
investment and then later in the
IPO of Alibaba and many other
things and then they built up the Softbank
vision found the first
technology like them  one of a
size of 100 billion
i.e. normally 50 million world
dominating ideas and demands and
one of them was to build the so-called
software Unicorn Colors,
i.e. the idea was that
Softbank found vision or Softbank
in general as a group found
itself more than others  Investment companies
that
were pictured would have
invested in technology companies and
invested in technology companies in such a way that
these companies would dominate the market as much as possible,
yes and Softbank he
invested in companies like uber at the time, we'll get to that in a moment
about the history
and many other companies and
actually had the philosophy  that if you
over-capitalize the companies, if you
invest disproportionately in these companies, the companies can no longer
fail and they will automatically become
bigger than everyone else,
which means that others will be so afraid of
big, strong opponents and that they wo
n't get any more money either
The idea software has given so much money
then its portfolio film also
so much money that all other
competitors can no longer get any money, everyone
else says okay, we
would never finance someone who
competes against a Softbank
right because that's way too expensive
If I have so much capital
then I can afford every team in
the world I can afford every marketing
campaign in the world and I
automatically become the market leader in many
things in many areas it
actually works so that was
one philosophy and the other
philosophy  It was said that
Softbank has or their
investment philosophy was
to invest in grow stage companies, i.e.
companies that already had a product
that already had a certain scaling
and in order to cushion this philosophy, so to speak,
and also to supply them with their own leads
or was the
idea of ​​creating this software unicorn farm,
which actually means
taking care of incubation of business models and building some kind of Rocket
Internet and steroids,
so when I was in Tokyo for the first time
and presented myself to Softbank,
it actually happened  So
taken as a reference, we want to
build a Rocket Internet of the world, we
want to build a start-up forge, a
unicorn farm that will be significantly larger,
significantly more successful than Rocket
Internet and we are
able to do this as software with significantly more
capital  to equip, so to speak,
the business models that
are currently not represented or these
certain countries do not exist, similar to
the Rocket Internet approach back then, to
build them up themselves and for that
they were looking for a CEO, so they were looking for a CEO of these
Softbank Unicorn colors and that
was my entry point, so to speak
for Softbank the vision was so big
and the capital that was behind it was
so incredibly large and in fact
the Softbank people around Marcelo Clare
and Masterson and others were
incredibly charming and convincing in their way
in what they did and of course
when the capital  I imagine it's
a bit like Messi
now at Miami told you okay, come on,
here's a huge box of money, now
please do it and something like that
and I thought for a long time
whether I should do that or not
because  delivery Hero came out in
2019 that I left deliver,
I had been building startups for 17 years
and after 17 years I was
traveling around the world,
living in startups in all kinds of countries in the world
and hiring delivery riders, making contracts, making
financing, making money trips,
exits or something like that
So the libery
IPO alone Katja, so to speak, resulted in over a
billion in proceeds and
I also led the delivery IPO together
with Niklas and
before that I had hundreds so
it probably comes to I don't know
now
2.5 to 3 billion euros that I have  I
probably solved it in the in the in
this career so at least
Japanese there at the start but did you
somehow found something or or
actually looked at the world so
I then, so to speak, my my my
former partners from food
partners from the Moneybookers time
from  Jan since I have
always tried to put the same team together
again in every company that we have built and supported because
we are friends because we
are very complementary and the success of
all these companies is significantly
influenced by this  was that we
were traveling as a team and and team as a
criterion for success in the broadest possible
team, the most complementary team possible, a
contradicting team that was but
friendly with each other,
that was a big success factor, that is,
I had a small team at
Jamba that got bigger and bigger
the cores took the core of this team with me to
Moneybookers I took the core of
this team with me to futbander
and then I took the core of
this team with softmen again
if not so it was a constant back
and forth um we were in or I was  in
Tokyo I was in Miami I was in New
York So the central of these
unicorn colors
has shifted several times,
especially because it was
initially about
building business models worldwide and it was
n't really about where you live,
but where  you build up these businesses
and we actually went to the
beginnings of this software
Unicorn, by the way, we
renamed it to Softbank techup at
Unicorn colors also for a Massa then
complained too sensationally and he
then wanted to officially change the name, so to speak
I actually have to spend the first few
weeks of months
looking at ourselves, like we did back then at Rocket
Internet.
This is the world, these are the
different countries, these are the
business models that exist in certain countries and are successful. There are the business models that do
n't exist in certain other countries
and then, um,
standard is about to collapse
and there was a
meeting
of all the Softbank portfolio CEOs with the
Softbank management
in Los Angeles in 2019 in words,
yes, this famous Adam human, he
was already in September 2000
September 2019, um I was in  In full
swing at Softbank
Mass personally only invited the portfolio
CEOs of all the companies where they had invested so far.
Management invited very, very
many invested
and during this event where
the success of Softbank and the vision actually
found and so they show the global
scaling and
wanted to celebrate and celebrate global dominance and
actually wanted to initiate the next phase of
software development
while this event is actually parallel,
um, this situation
presented itself differently than it
was actually intended
and it became clear during this event
without now going into this
confidential one  Details to go
that is on the verge of collapse
that weberg is on the verge of bankruptcy
in front of the college and had aggregated so many
billions in liabilities
and was the largest commercial real stay
tenant of buildings in the
western world  a
collapse of wework would not only have
brought big problems for softmenge, it would have brought
big problems for many other big investors,
but it would also have brought
big problems for the entire real estate world
because, as I said, the
largest commercial tenant in the
western world never has
Bought buildings but rework has always
rented buildings for 10 20 30 years at
sometimes horrendous rents which
of course could be afforded on the basis of very generous
funding
when I have a 10 20 30 year high
rental obligation
and practically
enter into new rental agreements every day all over the world
in the whole world
then this now interacts with
major liabilities that I have on balance
and if these liabilities
cannot be secured with appropriate
financing
then I have an insolvency situation
and we don't want the card anyway, not just what the what the
what the rents
but also
far too generously and far too
wastefully, there is
a lot of documentation on this and
in any case I was
kindly asked if I
could step in to save it operationally
and that happened faster than I would have liked and um,
so
to speak, I was then asked
to fly to New York
to the headquarters of rework
Softbank was in the process of
completing the purchase of wework because the
only way to save the whole thing was to
buy the whole thing, to
save yourself, to save the
other investors, to save the other investors, the only
way was to work on it
Softbank balance is to take and
buy to consolidate
everything else would have really changed in the
absolute catastrophe
and Softbank then negotiated the purchase of
wework
but there was wework with the
labilities with 10,000 of people with
a company that in the months where
This collapse almost generated a
loss of 300 million per month,
so there still had to be one, even
if it was on the Softbank balance sheet, to
restructure and save this company,
um, and I was kindly
asked if I couldn't help with that,
that was  the original the
original idea just to help,
I flew to New York and the
next day there was a meeting that
was broadcast live at CNC and everywhere, so the press pressure was also
relatively high
and I was asked on stage as
part of this meeting  I was
given another T-shirt Love
and I was presented, so to speak, as the German who would be
ridden over so that I would
take over all operational responsibility and at that time
the entire management was
dismissed as part of this purchase process,
so there was no cm oh  There was no CEO there was
no cityos there were so I
have no goals when it comes to management
and I was, so to speak, the
interim for everything
and I can still remember the
headline here in the German
Handelsblatt back then on a page
I don't even know  was relatively in the
relatively first pages the German who will
save WeWork so the
pressure was huge and I spent
the next few months actually working
day and night
to transform and restructure. I
also have parts of mine there again  Teams were
brought in, so to speak, who had a large part in ensuring
that we were able to restructure the thing
and bring it into something healthier
and of course it was
also clear even if we had
had the option, we would have had the
option or I would have had the option
also in the long term
than as possibly CEO of the company
but that wasn't something I
could imagine in the long term either. Yes,
I found it an
incredibly interesting
but also incredibly tiring,
stressful and often frustrating
experience to turn this store around,
which we said in in  I
managed to do certain aspects,
but it was a
unique experience that
on the one hand I didn't want to miss,
but on the other hand I don't
want to have it again, of course it leaves
a lot, so to
speak, we were always in
this mode of building companies before  to
scale, we managed to raise money,
we managed to sell the companies,
whether it was food Panda, whether it was
Moneybookers, whether it was delivery or the
IPO or Jumper back then and
this time
you got to know the whole thing, the whole dark
and almost evil
what this world what this technology how the
world can actually generate because there were
so many things within the company
and the documentation also talks
about the reality, which I
think is even more colorful, what is shown in the documentation
has been brought to light a lot  but with whom you came into contact was
brought into contact what was
really wrong bad also just
human evil partly but
example
how people treated each other
how people
mixed family interests with business interests like how money was used for embezzlement
like
cases of fraud
like how money was squandered
how things were covered up, how lies
were lied, how excesses
were celebrated within the company,
so of course that was no
longer the case when we came in,
but
it was it was it was it was a
family business of Adam and his
family, so many  Had family members
there, there were many cases of, say,
corruption that were uncovered
where certain service providers,
family members, friends were simply brought in.
There was a lot of bad
treatment of employees, which
on the one hand there was a good culture at
rework
which attracted a lot of people  There was
a a culture of creativity from
party from excess which
can be very attractive but sometimes
excess spilled over your and and and is so
to speak disadvantaged people
discriminated against people
and that I think many many tragic
cases where I think people
very unfair
very
insulting from this  circle of trust
were also excluded so they
were part of this bubble for a long time
and gave in to the excesses and
they certainly had a good time
but outside of that, it
's easy from a human, social, entrepreneurial and legal point of view, beyond the limits
but how long
I was there  then at weever for almost
a year and in the course of that one
year we
changed everything, turned everything upside down,
significantly reduced wework's losses, made
the company significantly more
profitable,
shrunk,
left certain countries,
adjusted the product, adjusted the valio proposition,
and then  I also found
a permanent management team together with the Softbank management team
and put it in place,
some of which I still don't know what has
happened since then, but I still believe to
this day that the company continues to be
worth a lot less on the stock exchange, but it's working  right,
yes, and after this experience, which
certainly also sunk for mass and the water
and the Softbank management
was a certain turning point because they realized
how vulnerable this system
is, that companies are over-capitalized, what
can that lead to
and Softbank is through that  wework
experience and then there were of course other things within the framework of
the general market environment, so to speak.
uber
developed differently, Alibaba also
developed differently, many
other Softbank investments had
developed differently despite the large amount of capital,
Softbank generally
became more cautious and conservative  and, above all, has
decided to no longer
enter into these huge bets,
to no longer invest billions in a single business model, to no
longer invest so
extensively and so large in certain
companies and also
to pause or end the idea of ​​continuing these unicorn farms
Because of the experience, software
no longer had the reputation to say that
we are now building up the big companies here
ourselves and so to speak, right
or wrong is so to speak, so to speak,
so I think when we look at
the big challenges these days
and I have a lot in the
last few  Now for months and
years and then even during the
Softbank time I thought about it and
thought back a little to where
I actually come
from in East Berlin. I spent a lot of time in
Cuba. I actually spent a lot of time
in
these contradictions in emerging and
developing countries  and even
when we, I don't know, brought our
different business models all
over the world, we
always had a big focus on the
emerging and developing countries and I
spent a lot of time on site
in these respective countries and also
from my own Cuban experience
and the many years  I haven't spent time in Cuba, you can
see with, um, you can see
and experience it for yourself that the world
can also be very poor, that the world
can become very complicated,
that the world can be very difficult and
sometimes very sad and that's something that an
incredible number of people have
I haven't been in contact since I
was a teenager or since I was a
child because Cuba is the
Caribbean and beautiful things and around and
great parties and a lot of music, um there's
poverty
in Latin America, there's a lot of poverty in
Southeast Asia  There is a lot of poverty in
India, where we have built our business model,
there is a lot of poverty in
Bangladesh in Africa and so on and then
you ask yourself sometimes and there
comes that softbank perspective again, there
is someone who invests 100 billion
in technology companies, there is
his enthusiasm  in this
tech industry
from entrepreneurship from capital
from world-changing ideas and I
was already at the Softbank time
that a perversion
had been achieved as far as
the money supply
and as far as the big ideas were concerned
where I was already at that time  I asked
what happens if you use this capital
or even just a fraction of the
capital's entrepreneurial energy
to solve some of the big
fundamental problems of this
planet
if we if you take the combination of
Jeff Bezos Masterson
that is not very profit from Google and
and Max  Sacher citizens and others if
you take them all together and the
capital that they have all raised
and look at how we build
structures
for a somewhat more sustainable world.
I'm not saying that we
can completely turn this world around, so to speak, but
we can create a better one  have an
impact if you channel it differently, what
would this
world look like
and this thought
has accompanied me again and again and
especially at this Softbank time or
when I also saw what
could become negative with wework
has me or accompanies me
I'm thinking more and more about
how you can do it, the
entrepreneurship that we have around the world,
the capital is still there and is
still there and
there's probably more capital today than
ever before because it's being invested less,
how can you do that  channel in order to um
I say to better secure the continued existence of
our existence on this on this
planet we
know then after your, so to speak,
understood how it was with over and what did
you have then so you left at
some point I assume
a good take, so in an
understandable way, it has a
different focus and then you
asked again what do I do now and then
you did something
a little different because we
actually
continued to operate this so-called unicorn farm on a much smaller scale during this time and  We
actually looked at which
business models can work in which countries
and in this respect Joker, the company that we
run today and continue to build and get
through thick and thin,
was a result of the Unicorn software,
which means that Joker was a
business model that was in use at the time
softbank times had already been developed
back then with a focus on
Latin America, but back then there
was a Turkish original, that's awesome.
I think it was the initial
idea, which was a combination of
the success of Turkey's
first beginnings, which we had back then  have
seen at delivery because deliver has
already brought this business model of fast delivery of food and convenience items to some countries.
On the one hand, this was
to show how a vertically
integrated fast delivery model
can be successful and again
can generate completely different things coupled with the
understanding of Latin America,
where the
density of supermarkets and the penetration of
supermarkets
is very low, it is not like in, let's
say, Berlin in London in New
York where I can find the nearest supermarket in a 15 10 15 minute
walk
In cities like Sao Paulo I have to
walk for an hour to get to the nearest
supermarket. Walking to the
supermarket isn't a great
experience either. Sometimes I don't have any
sidewalks at all. It's warm. There's a
lot of traffic. That's the effort in
a city like Sao Paulo
Doing my weekly shopping is
by far higher than if I
do my shopping in Germany or Great Britain or the USA. As
I said, supermarket density is completely
different, there are few other online
options to get it delivered to me,
so the idea behind this
business model was to do so  develop and
focus on Latin America a
mixture of
a lack of options in Latin America
a lack of online options and
poor offline options to
do your weekly shopping coupled
with the understanding of not only
building an online supermarket but
also a model  build that
fast delivery ensures that
these micro warehouses have these dark stores
and that guarantees a significantly deeper
integration into inventory
management and this
combination of both
has given us the conviction
that Latin America is the right model for this
business model at this point in time
is
initially sponsored by Softbank
and therefore when this WeWork
transformation came to an end,
I personally would have had the option
to stay with Softbank but
on the investment side
and even if I have been involved as an angel
investor in many other companies
over the last 20 years
I'm not the classic
investor, but rather an operator and
an entrepreneur and then we
said that the most promising
business model that we developed back then as
part of this unicorn form,
which was just a joker, that we would separate it out
and that we would build it separately
Unicorn then
became quite quickly
became Unicorn relatively quickly but the question is
Unicorns was of course, on the one
hand, due to the fact that we
grew operationally very quickly, that
sales grew very quickly
today
we also have several hundred
million in sales today we have that
Business has been very much adapted and also
adapted to this funding environment of the current reality that we have, so today we are
only active in Brazil.
Brazil was our first market back then. Brazil
was always the country that
generated the most sales,
always at least 70
Percent of the entire group turnover
generated because it's called Joker,
set up in exactly the same way as back then, so Rocket
website with the same playbook,
exactly this time, strategy, we
said let's try Brazil, let's try Colombia, let's try
Mexico, let's
calm down, let's
try Chile, let's go  Even
if capital is cheap right now, try
to make two cities in Europe
in which a gorillas nimble
have not yet been active here, which is why
I got two, a city in Poland and
a city in Austria, very, very small
but still two small mushrooms
that were put in the ground
simply to learn to see whether it
works, to compare with what
you don't have in America and we
also did that in Boston and New York
where we
set up a small, so to speak, small locations
Interestingly, the
customer was the custom adoption as they say,
so the customer interest and also
the customer lifetime value is very similar
between the countries, so the
recognition and use of the service
is because very similar between the
countries, surprisingly, you did
n't see it  that this has been noticed more in Brazil
than in, I do
n't know, Warsaw or New
York, this business model of
fast delivery,
strong personalization of the
right products at the right
time, a much better
online experience than the supermarkets
do or, um, because  They didn't see any other
existing online or offline players,
so they had a very similar
customer acceptance,
but when it comes to, as we
say, vertical integration, how do
we manage to build supply chain processes
that are efficient and that
guarantee us a relatively high purchasing power, we saw a clear difference
between Latin America and
Europe in the USA
because the profitability of this
business model cannot be
driven by the fact that I
charge more money from the customer, the more
money I charge the customer, that you
have fewer customers because the service
is then too expensive for many for many
Customer groups I also cannot
guarantee profitability by
simply squeezing my own delivery riders
and underpaying them and, um, so to
speak, initiating the next
level of exploitation, so to speak,
but I can
only be profitable in this business model
if I generate my initial sales
when I generate them  the shopping cart and the
shopping cart that I have, so if
I don't have a marketplace model where I
charge a strange amount from
the supermarket or restaurant,
but rather where I do the shopping myself,
I am the retailer myself
and where I have to have the opportunity to do so as
directly as possible  to come to the producer, be it
the pharmaceutical company, the fruit and
vegetable grower, the meat producer, the
fishing company or
the producer or the local
brewery, that I manage to
approach the producer as directly as possible,
that I have the best possible
purchasing conditions there and that I
The profitability of this
business model is not generated through the
efficiency of delivery, not through a
price structure, not through additional
services and advertising,
but rather that they ensure the profitability of
this business model through purchasing
and this is
achieved more in Latin America than
because I am in Germany
in the USA
In many other
Western European or other Western
countries, I'm forced
to go through wholesalers, which means my purchase prices
for fruit, vegetables, meat,
all sorts of other products, my
purchase prices are actually dictated by the market.
In Latin America and many
other emerging countries, I actually have the
opportunity to work with the farmer
with the producer in a much more
fragmented world or in a country
like Brazil that produces 90% of what they
consume themselves, which
is not dependent on imports, where I
have significantly better purchasing conditions,
and in this respect I have
a situation in Brazil today where  We
have a contribution margin of almost 35%
after all purchasing costs, variable
costs after
delivery costs,
warehouse costs,
customer service costs, payment costs and
so on and the contribution margin of 35%
is higher than what the best
supermarket in Germany or the USA
generates because we have better purchasing
I'm profitable because you
forgot because we
actually do two things: on the
one hand, we use the market warehouses
because there are no
other
equivalent online providers in Brazil,
so the market is very young and the
market is very underdeveloped on this side
is to take advantage of this situation to
grow as quickly as possible without spending
disproportionate amounts on marketing,
so we continue to invest
in growth and we continue to invest in innovation in order to
further expand our online business model.
We have now built an advertising
module where we certainly
allow brands to do so  our platform to
advertise we have
significantly expanded our inventory so that we
are not just a supermarket but are
developing more and more towards one of a better Amazon,
we would no longer invest in marketing
or would invest significantly less in marketing
and would we be what the tech  When it comes to
innovation, just do a little
less and then we will be
profitable these days, okay, what
steps should we take? So then Rio is
our Paulo Paulo and Bello horizonti,
these are the three
cities in which we are active these days
but have an aggregate turnover of 100
million
You have a population that is
almost the same as the population of Germany
and Brazil has a total of more cities
with a population of three
million people than all of Europe combined,
which means you can
imagine that if you are the market leader in
Brazil, it is roughly the same as
the market size than if you are  The
market leader in all of Europe is
involved in trickery, so that's
whether you're fair and honest, um
whether you're fair and honest
depends a little bit on
the market situation, of course,
I would say that we um at least
at least still close to this
valuation even after the
final market corrections yes because
I it is 20% more or less because the way
we are valued is an
an an abstract an an abstract
construct
that it basically just defines
to which  The price of new capital
can currently be raised.
I think the valuation of a company is only
actually defined at the time when the
company sells to the stock exchange on the stock exchange
then to a world map.
I'm still the um
I think I'm still the biggest
scissors or  yes really so we're
not talking about 40
different financial investors but
in percentage terms so 10 15% will
logically be something like yes if that's
the exit valuation
we can probably still then
your personally biggest at the moment
or
yes you have to number it first  One thing,
we are focused on getting the
company to continue to
grow. Growth
is still important. Growth and
profitability, so we have
month over month for this year to continue to grow the company.
We want to
be profitable next year,
probably more  around the end of
next year
and there are the
short-term goals and as soon as the company
is functioning in a sustainable, economic and sustainable way,
I think that's the time when
you can look at certain strategic options that you have
n't seen before and that also
combines a little bit of your own ambitions  We want to, um, we went
into this topic with full awareness.
We started much later
than a gorilla goes here
and many others.
We started with the topic when
the whole financial world
had already started to turn with the
awareness that we  We knew it was a
business model that we were convinced would
work in Latin America, at least in Latin America.
Of course, we took out money for it,
but we also knew
that it was a complex business model,
a complicated business model
that entails a lot of operational intensity,
but we also have big ones
I'm still
traveling all over the world. Of course, in the last few months I've been
very
concerned about
getting further financing. I'm very
lucky, I'm very successful, despite
the situation we're currently in
macroeconomically, um,
a new round of financing
can do right yes and we are
now in the process of
completing another round of financing
a mix of new investors from
strategic investors from
existing investors and the
mix of new investors
strategic investors exist
investors I
think is something special that
many others in the segment
not
currently finalized but in
the world, so to speak,
about the financing of joker
strategic partnerships
and I have a lot of time or
spend a lot of time in Brazil
as I used to spend time in I don't know
Asia Africa Middle East and many
other countries  I have lived and have
my official residence, but my official
residence is still between New
York and Berlin, so I
came into contact with New York back in the sad times when we brought the jamba business to the USA
lived in New York for the first time in the early 2000s,
later the Moneybookers business
in New York,
we then had Softbank's official
location in New York and have
therefore been based mainly
between New York and Berlin for many years
with all your
business angel investments  There are
any hits that
you might know that you're having fun with, what were
special moments, special ones for
you now, success, many of whom, um,
didn't have employees,
founded their own companies in which I invested
as an angel investor, um,
I know  not optician chains in
Saudi Arabia, there are
small tech investments in
Singapore, there are hospitality people who have
opened hotels in Mexico
or Miami themselves from
the tech sector, so there
is a Wild West
different business models that all
work well,
many of the companies are still
private, a large proportion of the companies are
actually profitable and
quite atypical for angel investments, so
to speak, there is now more income from
the actual dividends
than from certain exits,
which is
completely different  It
was different than expected from the very
early Jumper phase, still working at Joker today,
who only brought a relatively large number
with them all the years
until Joker, there are many careers,
right, so I still have
our Joker founding team and management
team  consists largely
of people I've worked with for 20 years
that's how many
people are there around you
so when he walks Panda we
of course not only have our
core management team and our core
founde team but we definitely have like that
I think the top 20 30 people from these top 20 30 people are a good half
of, so to speak, from all the
previous things, one day always
comes after Joker, you can assume that when
you attack somewhere again,
these 15 people will
hopefully be there again  more so
of course we have as part of the adjustment we have
as I said jokers were
active in many countries yes mushroom strategy and
we then focused it on Brazil
and we had an incredible number of
people our team in New York our team
Europe our team in Mexico those were
People who have worked with us before are
now
doing other things,
but of course if you have the opportunity
to work with these people,
I would not only work with those
who
are still part of Joker, but ideally
also those who are still
in your career  his network and
which he had, so to speak, taken with him over time
is actually the
story or you can link it, he can
now read personally that the
politician who is very well known in Germany today is Mrs. Weidel Alice Weidel,
but she worked at Footballer
and you with it  You ran into each other and she
had actually been at foodpartner for a few months,
so she was
an employee as an employee and um
it must have
been in 2014 or 15 it was
actually only about six months
and it wasn't before her
political career and it was
n't um
not an easy one  Constellation and, um, that's
why we
separated from here again, simply
because it became very political,
but it simply
has nothing to do with politics, I
think it was a different,
I think a different mentality  and
a different view of how to
build companies, how to manage,
how to lead people, what culture to
bring with you, was simply a different,
different understanding of the culture of
the corporate culture that we live and
had built up, okay, so I think it
was more of a culture clash
as
other, so to speak, I don't know
political or or professional
reasons and she first problem
probably even as an employee
right yes so we of course um
it was as far as I can remember in
a good CV and and with
good experiences and and the big one  The
big challenge when you
build startups on steroids that are supposed to expand from one location
to 40 is
of course always the question of the
people's talents. I need an
incredible number of people within a very
short period of time
and I can only function in such a business model
by handing over
responsibility  As CEO, I can't
be the micromanager who
takes care of every activity and every step in every country and it's a fine
line and sometimes you've obviously
over-controlled it when you
expand into 40 countries within 18 months,
so to speak. That's it  too
many countries too quickly and we
lose things too, but
I believe that what we
survive is a joker even in the
most difficult times and that's
probably why we managed
our ventures in all of the
difficult years at the beginning of the 2000s  from
2007/2008 in the difficult years of 2015
in the difficult year of 2022 and 23
to always navigate in some way
because we have a good team culture
and because we have learned how to
deal with each other like in a
partnership in difficult situations
and the um  simple situation
and the technology, the product, the
business model
is absolutely subordinate but the main
priority is that of course we
first had to learn over the many
20 years now the main priority is
who do I work with that the
main priority is to turn to the company
who do I work with  How do
I work with people,
what communication do I have, what
empathy do I have? How do you complement each other
and how do you create a unity
and the unity has to be as large as possible?
You are convinced that you cannot be successful on your own.
You can see it too  Not to be
successful with three people, you need a very
broad team and you need good, humane,
solidarity-supportive
manners and not
every single person is in a
team at all times, but I still have to
keep them together because this team energy
still gives me so much security,
security
and structure  that that that that's the
deciding factor at some point
you almost don't get too old for it at some point I mean you've been doing it for so long
it sounds at least
exhausting so worldwide
you probably spend a lot of
time on planes to get the money
together at this speed
You can do it for the next 10
to 15 years,
so I have.
It's actually very strenuous
if you do it for 20 years.
It's probably like doing competitive sports for 20 years  I've
actually done it for years or 20 years without a break,
but there's also
a lot of energy
from the people you
work with, so what do we do? We
're all social beings.
We like to surround ourselves with other people and
have families
Having friends and on the one hand there is
nothing better than
designing and building things with friends,
but it is a question of how much you
have to get involved in each individual situation and when I will be
able to not only go to the project but also be an
initiator  to be a
helper, to be an incubator and
perhaps to be
able to hand over more and more operational responsibility, in this respect
I have just, so to speak, Joker has
managed to
adapt and finance itself in this way
and now with the last
round of financing that we
are financed through to profitability  means Joker will
be a business model that can and will not only
be successful but also successful and
for me personally
an important chapter has
not been completed but
an important milestone has been reached because
we have a well-functioning
team in Brazil  NCA the business,
we have
structures that work, we are fully
financed so that I can take care of other things more
and more over the next few months and
then years
and my wish is to
pursue exactly what I said
before
How do you manage to use our experience and
my experience,
the access that I have to talent, to
great people, the access that I have to
capital, how do you manage to use that
and channel it so that it's
not just selling ringtones, it's not
just delivering pizza, it's not just in the
to transfer money
but
rather let me say structure activities to
build business models that
have a much more sustainable character
that are much more valuable, yes and as
I said I don't want to discredit
that food delivery is not valuable
but we are entrepreneurs, we have
created huge value and we have
built incredible teams
Billions then raised capital can
I somehow use it to
initiate or
help or build things myself over the next 20 years
that
can be more valuable in the long term, you have to say you have yours
if you listen to everything now then
you ask yourself  How did he build a family in addition to all the
things?
You had your children very early so that you were
19 or something like that, that means,
um, the family chapter was already there
or children at least in the
toddler phase because then it
was done very early for you so that you now
Last year you were also
able to concentrate even more on all the
work,
yes I think, so to speak,
in life you still always need the
balance and the contrast point
and you have to at least that's
my opinion, you have to create
an ekelebrium somehow
I can't just
work and not just
devote myself to a professional agenda
I think I need a social life
or every person needs a social
life every person needs a family
or has a family hopefully
whether you are the right family or a
family of choice that you choose  if you
annex yourself
and I think that the family itself
or the fact that I
became a father early,
maybe I took responsibility and hopefully I
wasn't or am not that bad of a father, it
helped me because it
was a balance to that  to the
traveling, to the work, to the stress, to
the constant building and creating,
it was a place of rest
but also a responsibility
growing up. We traveled a lot around the
world, we
also lived together in many countries and are
now back in Berlin
and my son has always finished his studies and is
currently orienting himself on what to do next.
My daughter is still going to school
and yes, we were, we were in many
countries in the world together,
okay, yes, so
you can be curious, it sounds
a bit like that  If
something new
could come out soon in the other area,
maybe and you're still looking a little bit to find out
what it is and whether it
could be from the operator, the
last question is what is your forecast
for the German market for the
delivery service,
that is yes  It's not quite clear yet do
you think the model will be able to be used
in Germany at all or quickly in the future,
so I think food delivery has
become a reality like
driving a taxi or,
I don't know, going to a concert
that had it
convenience factor it has an
entertainment factor it is a it is
in English they say it has become a habit
yes it has become a custom
that is called food delivery its reality
the demand for fut delivery exists
both for the restaurant sector and
for the food sector as
well  for an Amazon where to
order cables laptops books t-shirts shoes
the question is it is a highly complex
business model and why has Amazon
managed to be bigger and better than
many other e-commerce companies because
they have operation excellence and um yes
excellence in  Everything they do was
very important and operationally they
were better in the implementation of the
warehouse management, the supply chain, the
customer experience in terms of
reliability but because they also
had the opportunity to raise a relatively large amount of
capital and the question of
capital as well as the question of
Operational implementation is still
the core question for the fut delivery
industry, the companies that are the most profitable
or have the best access to capital
and the companies that are operationally
best positioned are the companies
that will
survive and that will win
and it stays that way  a winner text and
allmarkets I don't think there is any
justification for
having 3, 4, 5 different providers
and even if that is
not wanted under antitrust law, that's
just the input, but there is no reason
for the customer to have two or
to have three if there is one provider  There is
one who can solve all my problems,
why should I go somewhere else? That
explains Amazon's market power, so
in the end it will be Amazon and, um,
I think there will be one or two
large suppliers. I don't think there will be
an Amazon in the food development sector
There's always something like that for the Nicolas area
and hopefully delivery Hero will
enrich the shareholder for the food delivery clearly clearly
probably the closest thing to it for um
and then over all the
mercha the Hero is probably the most
included
Yes, as I said,
I think there will still be
a lot of consolidation on the quick commerce and food side.
I think there are still relatively
many or perhaps too many
players in the market and I believe that
especially in the European market  This area
will continue to consolidate over the
next maybe two years, with
every form of consolidation being
effective and every form of
consolidation
increasing profitability
and the reason why many of these
business models are not yet profitable is
not at all my question of
contribution margins is how we do it  I have already
discussed it before, but it is
a question of marketing investment and
at the moment when I am competing against others
by
having relatively high customer acquisition costs because there is a lot of competition, at that
moment it is difficult
to make such a business model profitable,
insofar as merger and
consolidation is the case  Path to
profitability and sustainability and
profitability and sustainability are
again more popular than in
recent years, which I think is also
healthy and is a good market correction
and a better basis for
a new and much healthier
group of new startups in the
There will be a
long journey in the next few years, a very
impressive life, what you
have taken with you, you can also press on your own
then contacts, you can only
imagine excerpts of it somehow.
I'm excited to see what happens in the next few years.
Joker just see
how it turns out and  where you're thinking
about bad again, thank you very much, thank you very much
to you too and yes, I'm looking forward to the
next time, all right, ciao ciao, thank you,
goodbye